hey hi welcome to ij likes some of you
guys
yelled at me because my white wall was
really white and you guys told me to add
some colors i'm wearing color i have a
nice plant
that's not real and i'm gonna put this
thanks for the pillow throw boy let's
start the show
hey guys welcome to ig likes a bunch of
you guys probably know this show from my
reviews channel which i believe i'm
probably going to retire that channel
because i don't really ever post on it
and i actually really like this show
idea basically ij likes is a show where
i show you guys things that i like
things that you guys send me that you
think that i would like and i show them
to you now in the old show i used to
just kind of showcase one product one
app one thing but in this new show i'm
going to kind of cover three different
topics for this first episode i'm going
to cover tech and gaming my favorite
youtube videos from the past week and a
little bit of fashion and beauty oh boy
we gotta cover all the bases how many
bases well there's four but
it's like i'm gonna cover three so first
up i wanna show you guys a few of my
favorite videos that i've seen this week
and i'm talking so fast but i can't help
it because i i just i had some coffee in
so let's just show you my first favorite
video which is a monkey doing push-ups
he's doing push-ups oh not only is he
doing push-ups he's doing freaking
sit-ups after i watched this video i
felt really bad about not going to the
gym for a couple of months so probably
gonna go work out because if a monkey
can do push-ups and sit-ups i should
probably be able to do at least a couple
too right
this video is by i forget his name is
jessie teters and his daughter they're
doing this cute duet it was seriously so
cute i pretty much saved everyone i know
and that's how you know a video is a
good video when you take that video and
you share it with your friends so if i
do that then i'm definitely going to
show this video to you
third up this is a video by ingrid miss
glamorazzi here on youtube and tyler
oakley where they
do a blind makeup challenge so tyler
does ingrid's makeup and i don't know
why but i was watching this and i was
dying laughing look up
i think okay i don't want to get it in
your eye
oh my god did i get it in your eyes
those are my lashes ingrid is so
freaking cute even by the end of the
video she's still just casually talking
like hey guys you know just having a
good time
and i mean the only way to really
explain how she looks is a hot mess
but she still looks cute i don't i don't
understand i don't understand how is
this possible i don't know
now on to
i guess science and technology because
that's what youtube classifies like that
category has anyway sony held their
playstation 4 announcement where they
showed us the new ps4 that's gonna be
coming out during christmas or holiday
season except
they actually didn't show us the console
at all but they did show us the new ps4
dualshock controller which pretty much
looks exactly like the previous version
and the version before that except it
has a nice little touchpad
look at that we're getting real fancy
aren't we sony they also have kind of a
little added light sort of like in the
playstation move controllers so i
believe it will be able to be used with
the playstation move
does anybody still use that i
don't know but let's just hold on guys
because there's a freaking share
button it's actually pretty cool i'm
kind of excited about that so you've got
to take a guess what the new ps4 would
probably look like i have a feeling that
it would kind of look like the new wii u
maybe black just a matte version of that
maybe a little bit bigger so that
doesn't feel so inferior great now let's
slap a sony logo on that beast and now
we can move on
google glass
just essentially glasses made by google
which they're dubbing project glass can
we take a look at this
i don't know if some of you guys were
around back when i used to live stream
my life but i wore a camera on my head
so these seemingly futuristic
nerdy looking glasses will let you do
just that take pictures take photos send
emails also give you kind of a real life
heads up display you can get directions
you can
i don't really know everything that you
can do but it's kind of weird it's kind
of crazy and if you guys want to be one
of the first 8 000 to get your hands on
it all you have to do is tweet at
project glass hashtag if i had glass and
tell them what you would do there's a
catch if you were chosen to be one of
the 8 000 you
have to buy them and they're fifteen
hundred dollars sounds like a deal
all right now we're gonna move on to i
don't even know what to categorize this
either i'm gonna seriously need your
guys's help as to what to categorize
each of these sections this is gonna be
kind of the fashion beauty whatever w
e so spring is one of my favorite times
of the year because i love bright colors
and that's when all of the colors start
coming out in stores so i've been
picking up all kinds of floral little
goodies i had some other stuff to show
you i don't know where i went all over
here you hold on most likely i'm
probably gonna wear this together this
shirt with
these floral print denim and these pink
antiques like are you kidding i'm gonna
be
spring chicken
clucking around the farm
what does that mean i don't know i've
also been obsessed with these neutrogena
revitalizing lip balm oh they've spf
well okay there's only spf in this one
the funny thing is is when i looked at
these i was like these look like a cheap
piece of crap this packaging is
seriously just it's ugly but to my
surprise this is my new favorite lip
gloss although i didn't realize they
were ten dollars until i got the
checkout i was like i'm sorry how much
is that chopstick i usually really hate
colored anything but the color is great
it goes on even and it's really smooth
so
kind of no i guess there's enough taste
kind of smells a little fruity
so i know this is kind of crazy but i
actually started using pinterest i've
had it forever but i'm pretty sure i'm
the last person on the internet to
really use it so i started posting some
fun outfits on there of stuff that i
wear that i'm pulling from pose which is
an app where you can tag your clothes
and you can find out where they're from
and so on and so on and so on i'm not
even sure what i said in this video so
i'll probably be putting links to the
descriptions of whatever i did in fact
talk about make sure you guys like and
favorite this video and be sure to
subscribe so you'll see when i post a
new video now most importantly i need to
hear from you guys because this is a
completely new type of thing that i'm
doing so let me know what you guys want
to see let me know what you guys like
send me everything that you guys like
pictures photos
some cute outfits that you guys are
wearing make sure you hashtag it ij
likes so i'll be able to find it tweet
it to me and i just seen that's all i
think that i wanted to cover today
yep that's it i'll see you guys in the
next video
be sure to let me know what you think i
should put here
this is terrible i'm pathetic
bye